- My friends say
you is a man,
but I say you is woman, no?
- Why don't you ask your wife?
(hip hop music)
Girls can be builders.
Girls can be anything,
like a boxer.
Come on.
That's it.
And again.
- [Basketball Player] Look at you, eh.
- That's right, keep it up, right?
I'm gonna have you up working for me soon.
- Starting to like her, (mumbles).
Husein.
Do you know who this is?
(mumbles)
This is Dushane,
Dushane was Top G in Summerhouse.
Stand up, man.
- (sucking noise)
So what? Did you bring any food
for us then, Top G?
- Rough.
You ain't got no one other
than these fucking kids.
- Less.
The fuck's wrong with you, man?
- Do you know the fuck's wrong with me?
How the fuck am I supposed
to know who that is?
He's such a bad man, where's he been?
What?
- [Blond Man] Get the fuck off me!
Get off me!
- Sick teeth, bro.
- (screams)
- Less than half my youngers turned out
to work after this acid thing.
You know they're making up excuses,
saying they've gotten
patted at the corner.
So what am I supposed to do with 'em?
- Get more youngers, get 'em shorted.
- Well, what the fuck is that?
There's four youngers down there.
How the fuck are we gonna
set in a few tonight?
- I got a new kid that wants to show up.
- Yeah, so what you telling me for?
- It's who he is, isn't it?
It's Jamie's little brother's (mumbles).
Listen, don't be nervous, aight younger?
You're part of the family now, yeah?
That means,
that you see anybody try pick on me,
or anything like that you got to step up.
Can you do that?
- Yeah.
- Can I rely on you, yeah?
- Well, I can't hear you bro.
- Yeah.
- All right.
- Are you seeing someone, Jaq?
- It ain't nothing special.
- Bullshit. You're over
there every fucking night.
- Hey, shut up man.
- That's exciting. 'S her name?
(silence)
- Shelley asked you a question then.
Don't be so fucking rude.
What's she called then?
This dyck of a golden pussy?
- Oh, shut the fuck up, man.
(laughs)
- Come on, what's her name?
- (sighs) Maude.
- What?
Maude?
What kind of crusty old
fucking name is Maude?
(laughs) What, how old is she, 80?
- Shut the fuck up, man.
- (laughs).
- Hey, look.
I know people who want
what you're selling.
And they're not the kind of people
to throw acid in your face.
- I already told you I don't
want you involved in this.
- I'd just introduce you.
- It's you introducing me
that gets you involved.
- I'm just trying to help.
- You help, all right?
- I'll see you tonight, yeah?
- Might have to work.
Dris is a fucking liability right now.
I'm basically doing two jobs.
- Then stay out of trouble.
- Why?
- What, do you care?
- Yeah. No, I didn't say that.
- No?
- No.
- No? That's okay. I'll be good.
In a bit.
- What the fuck does that mean?
Step back.
- Keep on running the corners.
- That's Jaq's job.
- No it ain't Jaq's job,
it's your job now.
- What?
- Jaq's stepping up
to your back.
- Lauren?
(crying noises)
What's up?
Tell me what's wrong.
If it's a fella, I'll fix him good.
- (sobs) He's not done
anything, he's dead.
- What happened? Who is this guy?
- Promise you won't tell.
- Who am I gonna tell?
- His name's Leyton.
- What?
You mean "Leyton from the fields", Leyton?
(ominous music)
(bell rings)
(gunshots)
(car engine revving)
- You know if he was the one who had a pop
at Sully at a cremation?
You need to tell me what you told him.
(crying noises)
Tell me!
Did you tell him
that Sully was gonna be at a cremation?
- No, no. I don't know,
no, I just told him stupid shit,
shit that didn't even matter.
- How are you supposed
to know what matters?
Fuck man!
Listen, you need to tell
me whatever you told him.
Can't believe you stupid bitch!
(screams)
(whacking noises)
No man!
Fucking stupid bitch!
(screams)
Dumb bitch!
Dumb--
- Help me!
- Bitch!
(screams)
- Jaqi! Please!
- What's up?
Talk.
- It's Lauren.
Found my fucking sister's a snake.
- What you talking about?
- She's was seeing that Leyton guy.
That anything she heard, she told him.
- Like what?
- She told him about Sully going
to the cremation.
- (scoffs)
I need to see her now.
- I can't give her up, man.
- You got any fucking sense?
You go find her before I fucking do,
I swear down.
- You tell anyone what you told me?
- No.
- I have to tell Sully, you know that?
- Yeah, I know.
- And you know what he's
gonna do when I tell him.
- She's already gone.
- Naw, she ain't left.
She's at Shelley's.
- Fucking stupid--
- Yo, yo, hold it down.
Go and see her tonight.
Tell her to get out and don't come back.
Give her that.
She's gonna need as much as she can get.
- You lost me a lot of Ps, bro.
Now you gotta pay me back.
So you got my Ps?
- No.
- So you're gonna have to
do something for me, dunnit?
- Go on, take that.
Pick up the fucking bag.
(faint conversation)
(techno music)
- [Jamie's Brother] Fuck me!
All right! Help!
- [Policewoman] Firearm.
- No no, that's not mine,
I don't know how that got there,
that's not mine.
- I went and told them everything.
It was my bag.
You, nor Steff, nor Abby,
had nothing to do with this.
- Are you fucking for real?
You're telling me you're
out with him as well?
I send you two out together.
You know better than him,
and he knows fucking better than you.
Walk one for your shit.
Acting like fucking dickheads.
Why am I paying for you
to come my house looking all nice for?
I put money in your pocket,
I dressed you.
My jacket, my hair,
my trainers, my jeans.
Everything you're wearing is me.
(rap music)
♪ Of them that were happy ♪
- The three liter?
♪ They least expect it ♪
- Yeah?
- Like that.
- How much for?
- 10 Gs.
- Yeah?
I'll give you 25. Cash.
♪ Angels in the morning,
demons in the noon ♪
- [Car Salesman] Cash?
- Cash.
♪ Ever consumed by beating off the moon ♪
- [Car Salesman] Good.
(laughs)
♪ They're in the moment ♪
♪ Faced with the truth ♪
♪ Just ain't gonna know
what's the right thing to do ♪
♪ The life of the little ♪
♪ The life of the great deal ♪
♪ Life taking life ♪
♪ Deathmakers faced for life ♪
♪ Vain fights of ♪
♪ Vain flights of ♪
♪ Hands are tied ♪
♪ Sick and damn tired ♪
♪ The cold truth makes
room for the warm lives ♪
♪ Oooh ♪
♪ Sometimes ♪
♪ It feels like fighting for ♪
♪ Wasting away ♪
♪ Fighting for ♪
♪ Oooh ♪
♪ Sometimes ♪
♪ It feels like fighting for ♪
♪ Wasting away ♪
♪ Fighting for ♪